今回地区得意体育について伺っていきたい
んですけどそもそもこの3つってこうどう
いう言葉なんですか
ねこれはもう教育について教育の目的やね
世界中が言ってることじゃないどこも地
特に体育を目的として教育をするわねだ
から日本もそれ一緒なんだけど日本の場合
それぞれ地区は地区の到着点目的これは何
なの育の目的は何なの体育の目的は何なの
これ全然知らずに我々も教えてもらって
ないじゃないよくうちでよとやっとる時で
も乗れるようになるとみんな自由に乗りた
いって言い出すん好きに乗りたいです乗っ
てこいよいどうしてかわからんどこ行って
か目的がないんやだからあそこ行けて言わ
れたらさーとそっちへ行けるんやけど好き
にせえ言われたらどうしていいかわからん
ようになっちゃう教育も一緒だよ地区とは
こういう目的だからそういう目的に合う
ようにやれとそういう風に教育戦と目的
達成できんよね例えばね音楽って何の目的
でやると思う分からんやろここは何の目的
なんだ数学の目的は何なんだそういうこと
を全くこれ文部省が分からんのかな我々も
学校行っとる時に聞いてないしただ教わる
ままにはいはい言って聞いとっただけあれ
は間違いじゃないか
な
地区目的は論理的思考能力を作ることだ
これは人間だけができること科学的にもの
を考える正しく考えるこれが地区の目的な
んよ地区が色々ある中で例えば論理的思考
能力を作るためにやってんのが数学だ
みんな数学でもの考えるんやからね昔文化
系大学受験の時に理科数学がなかったじゃ
ない理科数学がないのに主催になれたこれ
おかしいんや理科系はちゃんと理科数学が
できんと成り立たんからだから論理的思考
能力があるじゃないでこの文化系が数学
免除理科免除というこれがまずかったんや
ねだから教育でも今の教育科学的に考え
ないじゃない目的もなしにやれていうだけ
で生徒はどうしていいかわからずにちゃる
しもっといは偏済が目的になっちまうそれ
だと偏差済有利な社会になっとるからね今
みんながものを覚えゃいいんだ考える必要
ない人が考えてくれたことを覚えればいい
だからだんだんダメになっていくわね教育
は文化系がやってるんですか教育は文化系
がやっとるからいかんのやない教育学部は
文化系だよだからいかんのじゃない数学の
先生あるいは体育の先生学校で偉くなれ
ないじゃない文化系の先生ばっかりが偉く
なるじゃないそういうね考える力のない人
が教育に携わっとるもんで考える力のある
生徒を養えるわけがないよね自分ができん
ことを教えたってそれはだめ
だ校長の言う文化系と理科系の違いって
いうのはどういう定義なんですかえ文化系
はね結果から違いが分かるんよ理系という
のは成果を上げてないよどんなに偉そうな
こと言っとったって結果出せんやつは理科
系としてはダメな文化系は結果関係ない
やろたくさんものを知っとるとか記憶力が
ええとかそういうことで偉くなってるじゃ
ない記憶力人が作った知識そんなもの
しょうがないんじゃないあれはねあの俺が
いつも言う思考合一に反する日本の精神論
は地を合一知っているということは行動
できるできるということなんだ自分が結果
を出せないやを知ってると言ってはいかん
ない安間なんか見とったら分かるやろ喋っ
とるだけで何もできんもんでこの前の安ま
なんかもあれ6回目かな出たのは最初から
連中の行と同じことばっかりやそれは50
年前にマスコミが言っとったことを今また
言っとるんやうちを責めるのになお前ら
進歩しないのと言なってくるよねそういう
ことでうちをやっつけれると思っとるヤら
の世界ではそれでやっつけれるんだ実際に
やらんでええからねそこがいかんとこでね
精神はあくまでも地行合一自分ができる
ことは自分が知っていると言ってもええ
できんことを知っていると言うな知らんの
よ地とはそういうもの知識というのはね
大体知識の式ごんべにこういうやつやな音
書いてあの式っていうのはねソフトウェア
という意味だ正しいことをやれば正しい
ソフトウェアができるやろ単なるち彼らの
知識にもなってないやろやってないんだ
から教育なんて携わったことのない奴らが
うちを責めとるわけよお前んとこの教育
おかしいって知識のもなってないじゃん
やったことない文化系の世界だからいかん
のよ成果をあげなくても
よろしい喋ればええ知ってればええこれが
チクできなきゃだめだよ行動にさないだ
精神とはそういうもんだ精神は行動の
プログラム地だけあったって知識になって
なければあんなものは精神とは言え
ない校長のチクのお話でよくマスコミが
一緒に出てくることが多いかなと思うん
ですけどマスコミとチークの関係について
伺ってもいいですかあれ偏差済ばっかり
じゃんだからマスコミの人間っというのは
実際に現場にはいないんだから彼らが今
言ってる問題点大体私の悪口を言うのが
マスコミの責任だと思っとるからねそれに
ついて悪口を言うとか批判するとかいう
能力があるはずがないじゃない正しい知識
は持ってないんやから自分でやってないん
だけどそれなのにそれを言うからあいつら
おかしいんや偏差さ何にもやらんでも知っ
ていればそれでいいと思っとるこれ我々の
世界ではバカっって言うんやけどねずっと
前出た時にあなたマスコミ嫌いでしょって
言いやがるそれなのにどうして出るんやい
あいつら出してやるというつもりでおる
もんでね言ったって俺マスコミ大好き言い
たいこと言えるじゃんだけどマスコミ人は
大嫌いじゃんバカばっかり
じゃん自分の出きもせんこと知りもせん
こと知識もないことそれで持って人を責め
とるじゃん自分が偉いと思い込んどるだ
からいかんのだ特にリベラルの人間って
いうのはそうな自分が正しいと思い込ん
どる単なる哲学哲学は科学じゃない正しい
かどうかは分からんだからあんなに
たくさん哲学があるわけやろ哲学が
正しければ哲学1つだけよ仏教みたいにな
受業みたいに1つだけになるはずや
いろんな哲学を作るじゃんみんな正しく
ないようわかるにゃそれ
を特に中哲学が素晴らしいもんだと
思い込んどるよリベラルの哲学の1つやろ
だからその素晴らしいものを知っとる私は
素晴らしいんだとこれがリベラルの怖さや
ねマスコミの中には理科系的な考えの人は
いないんですかね理系の考えは非常に
少ないんじゃないかなこの前のはやぶさ
みたいなああいうな理系的な出来事がある
もんで飛行機が墜落してどうのこうのとか
ちょっと理科系的に考えといかないような
ことがあるもんであの理科系の人間も入っ
とるはず
やところがね前のほら日光機のジャンボの
事故の時あの時に俺はまだコチ症に入っ
とった思て暇でな新聞をずっと見ジャンボ
123便かあいつを追っとったんよそし
たら新聞に美が吹っ飛んじまったとダッチ
ロールを起こして山に落ちちゃったんやね
そういう風に書いてある同時に乗っとる
写真を見るとちゃんと美はついとるん
そんなことさえもわからんっていうのかな
誰かがあの美がすっ飛んだからこんな事故
起きたんだていうことを言ったやつがおっ
たらそれをそのまま事実としてあれし
ちまうだけど自分の
とこの写真を見ると墜落した時に病が映っ
とるわけやないかれかこれが文化系やだ
からいかんだ検証しないうちの記事でも
そうやろうちのいいとこは1つも書かん
やろあれも悪いこれも悪いと悪いことは
100%悪いように書くじゃん馬鹿なんよ
あなどうしてうちで治ったんだ裁判で否定
されたからだそんなことないよ裁判で
ちゃんと教育的効果があったて言っとるよ
一心はね記者を典型すもの変化の順番それ
が全然わからん自分がやったこともない
理解できないんよねこれがいかとこない
論理的にものを考えないそれが地区やろ
数学以外に地区でこういうことをやるとい
いっていうものはあります
か今日本がまだああいう偏差催が支配して
もまだ持っとるのはどうしてやと思う問式
だ問式を小さい頃にやっとくと論理的思考
能力ができるんだだったら学校は
取り入れれええやろ幼児教育にところが
文部省は民間より自分たちが上だと思っ
とるであんな素晴らしい教育を自分たちの
教育の中に入れようとせんのや体験を払っ
て雲3人のところでやっとくらえばええや
ないかそしたら今の偏差済は減るよそう
いう文部省の役人が偏差中世だからダメな
論理的に考えれん自分たちは偉いから自分
たちの言うことが正しいと思い込んじまう
ね教育全体なんやけどリベラルでやるな
リベラルを追放ししま
教育会から教育は正常化するよこれもう
やった国があるんだイギリスそやった
やろイギリスが社用の国になっちまって
どんどんどんどん国力も低下するでもう
だめだという時にイギリス病って言ったわ
ねあん時にそれは教育の結果だという言っ
て教育改革した人がおるんやさっちゃやで
女やぞたし鉄の女やけどね彼女のおかげで
教育が正常化してイギリスを持ち直した今
の日本と一緒やないか今日本どんどん
どんどん落ちていってイギリス病より
ひどい日本病になっとるよ教育でなるやん
だけどマスコミは絶対そいつを言わん自分
たちがリベラルだからリベラル教育が
間違いだとなったら自分たちが間違いだと
いうことになっちまうもんであいつら全部
国作だ自分たちのメツを立てるため設ける
ために日本が潰れてもええんだヨーロッパ
やた革命をね民主主義の定義からして
マスコミや文部省のような腐った権力
取り除かんといかんのその取り除く力が
国民にあるんこれが民主やろ権力の交代性
ところが国民がリベラルになっちまっとる
だから文句言わん対局を見る目がなくて目
の前ばっかり見てなリベラルの教育の仕方
見てみ子供の今ばっかりに焦点がやろ今
かわいそうだとか今喜ばせようとか将来
どうなるんや仏教で言うように楽あればく
ありだ教育初期の段階でこれ以上ないと
いうような楽をさしてもらったもん成人し
てからダメになっとるじゃん誰が作ったん
やリベラルが作ったんやどうしてそんな
リベラルがいつまでものっとるん教育に
マスコミがリベラルだからね新聞の罪だ
毎日新聞の罪だな読売はもっと頑張らんか
い保守に近いんやけど産経はよくわからん
のやないかなあれ3見てこらん政治乱は
保守だ社会面見てごらんあれはリベラルや
ね社会面が保やないといかんのだえっとね
私の言うことは正しいことばっかりだだ
から今からまだ続くからえ正しい人生
満のく人生それを送りたけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ